نعم ايمان ولعلي انطلق من الرشقات
الصاروخيه التي ضربت تل ابيب اليوم حيث
اعلنت كتائب القسام عن استهدافها ل
لاستهدافها لمنطقه تلبيب الكبرى بعدد من
الصواريخ دوت صفه الاندار في اكثر من 30
موقعا وسابقا كانت سرايا القدس ايضا كانت
اعلنت عن استهداف مناطق في غلاف غزه لعل
هذه التطورات اللافته تاتي بينما اتجهت
الانظار ايضا الى تصريحات متلاحقه لقاده
عسكريين اسرائيليين عن عمليتهم في منطقه
الشمال هذه المناطق التي شهدت اشتباكات
عنيفه خلال الاسابيع الاخيره وتوغلت
للقوات الاسرائيليه بدا الحديث الان لدى
على لسان مثلا المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي
ل لصحيفه واشنطن بوست حديث عن اعاده النظر
في التواجد في الشمال بل
وتقليص كثافه هذا التواجد في المنطقه
الشماليه اذا نحن نتحدث عن معطيات جديده
بعد ان شهدت اكثر من منطقه على غرار
جباليا وعلى غرار الشجاعيه وعلى غرار ايضا
بيت حانون وهذه المناطق جبل الريس وايضا
منطقه الشيخ رضوان كلها شهدت اشتباكات اذا
منطقه الشمال مرشحه ل مقاربه ربما
اسرائيليه جديده في التعامل في التعامل
معها مع استمرار المقاومه في هذه المواقع
لو انتقلنا الى المنطقه الوسطى وتحدي ذا
مخيمات البريج والنصيرات والمغازي ولكن
ايضا منطقه الزوايده هذه المناطق ايضا
تعرضت اليوم لعمليه قصف اسرائيلي استهدفها
وبالخصوص في منطقه الزويده ياتي ذلك
استهداف هذه المنطقه الوسطى مع التطورات
التي ذكرناها في الشمال ولكن ايضا بموازاه
حليت الونر عن نحو مليون و900 الف نازح في
قطاع غزه ولعل المنطقه الوسطى كانت الملد
لكن انها الان تتعرض الى هذا القص لو
ذهبنا الى المنطقه الثالثه وهي المنطقه
الجنوبيه التي تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه لعل
الحديث بالاساس عن هذه المناطق الشرقيه
والمناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه حينما نتحدث عن
جرارا وعن الزنه وعن بني سهيله وغيرها
هناك اشتباكات عنيفه على مستوى هذا المحور
وعمليه قصف مكثفه في هذه المناطق في
المحور الجنوبي مع حديث اسرائيلي ايضا على
ان منطقه الجنوب تعد من المناطق المستهدفه
خلال هذه المرحله من الحرب لعلنا نختم
بالحديث عن تطور اخر وهو على جبهه جنوب
لبنان حيث شهدت هذه المنطقه عمليه استهداف
هنا في منطقه خربه سلم وذلك من خلال
استهداف احد القاده الميدانيين لحزب الله
هنا في خربه سلم في الجنوب اللبناني هناك
عمليه ايضا قصف اسرائيلي على اكثر
من منطقه في الجنوب اللبناني ولعل ذلك ما
يطرح تساؤلات متعلقه بخيارات ومقاربات
الحرب على مستوى هذا المحور اذا تطورات
لافته على اكثر من من صعيد في الشمال في
الجنوب وايضا على مستوى جبهه لبنان تحتاج
الى تحليل عوده اليكم ايمان واللواء الدو